>>Culture at this school
is not something
that adults steward for kids.
Culture at King is something
kids do for all of us.
Kate is our assistant
principal of student support.
She facilitates culture
in this building.
And Kate's in charge of everything
that leverages the critical thinking
that our kids have
developed, and focuses them
on our virtues as kind of a filter.
>>Kate: So the four virtues
that we focus on here
at our school are wisdom,
justice, courage and humanity.
In leadership we talk a lot
about just how we can build
and foster those virtues
within the school.
They watched a film last week,
the movie 'Pay It Forward.'
And so they're gonna be kinda using
that film as a jumping off ground
to discuss those concepts.
>>My name is Gabriela Ballesteros.
I'm in eleventh grade.
I'm a junior and I go to Kipp
King Collegiate High School.
>>Kate: So Gabi came to us from
a traditional middle school,
so a non Kipp middle school.
>>Gabriela: It was horrible.
It was a lotta gangs and a lot of bad
things and drugs and all that stuff.
Like everywhere, you would
just see it everywhere.
>>Kate: In the ninth grade year,
really struggled academically.
She's also an English
language learner.
>>When I first came here,
it was totally different.
I didn't expect it to be this way.
It was like really strict.
>>And this year has been, you
know, really-- doing really well.
She's stepping up in her
leadership all the time.
>>Gabriela: -- the idea of 'Pay It
Forward' is more powerful than him,
because even when he
chose to take on his--
>>Kate: The last two years, she's
really just started to own who she is
as a person, who she
can be as a leader,
and I think that's been pretty
transformative for her too.
>>I'm mostly proud of
everything I've accomplished here.
Like just all the hard work.
>>I have accomplished so much.
I used to like just not care,
but they say it'll be worth it,
and now I realize that
it is worth it.
>>Jason: I think what makes
these transformation predictable,
I think what is kind of the
foundation of what happens at King,
is that every day that our kids walk
through those double doors and come
into the school, they know every
adult they see throughout the day is
someone who knows that they're
capable of succeeding at the level
of expectation that's held for them.
>>Kate: I think that when
every teacher believes truly
that all the students in the
building can and will learn,
and they're devoted to doing
that, day in and day out,
not only is it more fun and more
joyful to be in the building
and to learn and to
teach, but it works.
>>Gabriela: Well, going to
college for me, it means a lot,
'cause I'll be the first
one in my family to go.
It'll mean a lot to my mom.
She struggled so much with
me, and just even for me,
'cause I know what
I wanna do in life.
But I just-- I don't know
how to get there yet.
>>Kate: I mean, I definitely
see Gabi going to college.
I think she would be-- I think
Gabi would be a great teacher.
>>Gabriela: I wanna be a teacher.
>>It lightens up my heart
how much they do for us,
that I wanna do the same.
Help people that are like me.